I think a lot of the Iranian novels of
the last 20 years or so highly overrated
I don't think they they have good
writing in them and I don't think it was
priority for those writers to push
themselves in terms of writing
nor was it a priority of their
publishers to put out great writing I
think they were selling again the image
of a woman in a veil crying maybe in a
kitchen so I'm very frustrated with that
and I hate to say that on some level but
I I do take it personally that some of
the writing is so bad I wonder if those
people are writers even you know it's
not enough to have a story to tell
everybody has a story to tell I I really
believe that and then there's there's
cycles in history where one person's
story becomes more relevant than someone
else's say but what goes around comes
around always and so I just think that
when you compare the sort of literary
tradition you were in Iran and then put
that up against those types of books
that have come out the immigrant
community the Exile community it's just
shocking I mean Iran was a country where
you had such a progressive poets like
floral ferrule sawed one of the you know
greatest confessional poets probably in
all of history you know writing this
incredibly candid startling verse in the
50s and 60s and then you also had a
writer like saw death Hidayat who you
know could could be talked of in the
same breath as Camus you know and Sartre
and his sort of intensely scary
incredibly progressive and innovative
writing and then and then to compare it
with the stuff that's come out it's sort
of embarrassing it's like you know
looking at the great Indies versus
Hollywood blockbusters so that that
motivated me to try to write a book
where where the actual sentences were
were uh you know rich and and well done
there are a lot of the female writers
you know I've I've been sent their books
before and I their shadow has sort of
followed me a lot you know and I'm sort
of expected been expected to embrace
them and say we're all a happy family of
these female Iranian writers that if
anything I think they made it tough for
me to get my book published because I
wasn't interest in those buzzwords I
wasn't interested in telling that same
story that seems to over and over
capture Western audiences I wanted to
tell a different type of story and I
want to continue to write a different
type of book I'd like it to be
incidental that I'm Iranian eventually
but for the time being I'm sort of
interested in some of those Middle
Eastern issues I happen to be so I might
linger there for a little while longer
but my hope is that I can eventually be
freed of what's expected of a person
with my background